[Music]
how good my
name here in a creepy freaking
Subway and uh we're going to use the
fuse to get past this door like I said
the fuse is played now Sesame batong
open I
did so good at this game it's crazy it's
crazy Gotta Love starting with the
loading all right whoa what was
that good tires good steering good
quality what's better batong is better
that's what I oh look at this beautiful
fappy family the best who what the
[__] freaking looking at Family PO is
going to kill you holy [__] scared me
what the
[__] all right let's try that
again pick up the fuse let's not look at
the family poster this time mhm all
right here B here man iic though all
right what whoa you little sneaky [__]
there you go I stab it Hobie stabby
Hobie don't I have look at my health by
the way I'm in trouble all right you
little girl trying to stab me while I
look at the best care for depression
that's not
the all right
whoa hello no ha oh no where is the VPN
gun I don't get it I don't get it why I
want the BEP quick 7 can I can everyone
loves bunnies all right we're in the
Stockholm Subway this is just a normal
freaking subway stockh
information stage whoa what was that can
I read this list without anyone [__]
all right how do we get past these you
can't oh you jump like
whoa oh oh okay you just walk through
lovely
hello who R's momb okay what do we do
R's momb slap that
[__] I need help and I need his bad I
need
drugs all right let's just go through
this [__] again I guess can we go here
the door is broken that's
Splendid all right let's go [__] with
Ruben not fck room with on just [__]
with her a little bit I need that oh
wait I have other guns though yes taste
she will taste it and she will like it a
lot all right boom boom boom
boom she liked it so much she ate her
own hand that's when you know they like
something oh look at that someway I hear
something over here what the
hell what is that
sound what the yeah let's not go close
to the subway
vagina okay anyone else want to [__]
with
nothing all right it's okay this creeps
me out as
hell all
right far far
far whoa don't trip in the stairs Buddy
save PE I know I was supposed to write
something by rubbish mom don't don't
don't don't come near me don't come near
me I dare you
just back off back off stay there stay
there no no no no no no run run run run
run run Plan B Plan B Plan B Plan B Plan
B Plan B all right that didn't not to
work as plan maybe she will live whoa
that freaking random thing is so Random
R Mom oh she can't walk stairs H she's
handicapped all right I'll just take
this like a boss silly Ruben's mom
doesn't realize anything you're so
stupid taking photos and everyone will
laugh everyone will laugh so much at you
Ruben Mom oh my gosh everyone will laugh
so much all right let's go she's still
there oh oh rumor's Mom you're a feisty
one aren't you H you can do [__] bro you
can oh wait do I have to go there later
I think I have to go there later son of
a [__] I'll see you soon lady R's mom
just going to go over here
hello God damnn it I can't go there all
right rors Mom you win this round but
next round is cookies no Whoa stop
moving rooms mom stop enough of this
[__] all right let's go in here cuz I
said so oh no creepy corridors oh no
creepy
corridors SN SN okay I don't know
why [__]
okay s
hallelujah hallelujah hallelujah
hallelujah don't look kids no not this
is not drugs this is T tby pills
thingies all right this is no scoping
time on that freaking baby thingy all
right let's just say hi to her hello
girl how you doing that no scope no
scope poop down all right a Glock Magus
do I have yes I have the Glock how dides
that feel teabag you and your baby
that's kind of wrong I guess but she got
no scope okay we can't go in
there no let's not go there let's go in
here what is this hey Morlock lovely
Ruben bomb back off I no scope you I
don't dare me no scope you right in the
face that's what you get for being no
scop B I'm going to stay there all
right actually just give me one moment
and I'll check what it was I was
supposed to run all right this had 66
thumbs up so bind
F5 save Pew what the hell oh wait sorry
I
forgot bind
F5 say oh wait wait wait there we go two
times in a row yes did it work all right
nice thank you bro that's bro tastic
isn't it and then load Pew right here
all right let's try
it did it work I don't know we'll see I
guess we'll see let's go in here wait
wait just a second oh okay oh no I can't
no scope anymore well God damn
it we should probably reload this gun
before we go in here all right you ready
Bros I'm not ready never
[Laughter]
ready oh my
God you little
ah senorita bu the cono let me see you
move like you come oh no that's the door
with Ruben's mom in the background where
did she go B Inception okay sorry let's
go in here now I expect more freaking
frers freaking fers come here let just
take it really [__]
easy let's just go here
hello I got my eyes on you got my eyes
on my money and my eyes on what that was
not how the Lo goes I think whatever got
my got my fire on my no wait what all
right now we have to deal with Ruben's
mom the question is should we just go
for
it oh I have to
hurry son of a [__] ruid mom you make
me piss all right we have to hurry
apparently
well why do you what can a man do when
you're just a man not much all
right why would it go back it makes
whatever whatever whatever I'm clicking
clicking like about run like a b run
like a b like a run like like run you
woman man Simon Okay you can't waste all
your stamina cuz otherwise you run
really slowly so you got to do it like
this hey R Mom how you doing [__]
me God damn it why why why I thought for
[__] on the snitel that it would work I
ran and I ran good you you saw it God
damn you had to be really fast all right
fine let's do it what
but no senorita
no
what what it it was red I
swear I think it's is a bug let's try it
again what
a oh that's the door that's the door
that's the door all right let's go with
the Ruben's mom
door Ruben's mom door Ruben's mom door
Ruben M Ruben's M you probably have less
time on this one cuz probably further
away I mean closer it's easy to get
those all right rben Mom door rben mom
door rben mom door Ruben's mom door
yes like about all right let's call our
mom
oh liking the
movies no one in here all right like in
the movies like a b can we go in here no
of course
not all right let's go and see what
happens in here
what what am I doing in here wasn't I in
here two seconds
ago what I'm I'm what I'm totally mind
[__] right
now what what what was the point of
what no how did did I walk through
there what oh it's a shortcut I need the
shortcut
probably yeah all right so where's the
other door
then it was next
to M [__]
Sorita M A don't trip and Grace see what
I did there maybe it's on the other side
of the subway probably let's check just
for fun I love it love it love it love
it
m love it sh be quiet vagina sometimes
you just wish yes there it is all right
sometimes you just wish vaginas were
more quiet and polite and doesn't have
hands and weird things going out of it
everywhere freaking B giant man all
right all right let's see if we can I
say all right wait
F what is
that okay whatever doesn't matter let's
take this cuz I'm too lazy to walk
pretty NE un neat dun what do we got
Sven on legal servus I'll be sure to
contact them
eventually
okay let's see if we can do this
okay put on your running shoes boys
let's do this it's this
one go go go go go go go go go go go go
go go go go go go go go go go God damn I
have to run a lot this is a problem all
right rul Trapper don't fail me R
Trapper there we go all right run run oh
no running out of stamina running two
cent wait shut up you're Dy I'm running
here all right where is it where is it
how do I oh come on baby don't you dare
don't you dare
yes oh don't jump warning low battery no
no no son Sony xon Sony please please
please son Exon Sony Sony
whatever
[__] that's what you get oh wait I have
my F5 I don't trust the F5 I'm sorry R
mom stop eating yourself literally Sony
Sony on don't fail me Sony whatever you
do Sony I love you
Sony oh start moving are we supposed to
take
it oh vagina you're going to get
some penetration listen and learn boys
and girls watch and
learn I don't really I don't really know
okay there we
go all right right I did it what does
this
do what what happened what did I do what
did I what did I freaking do maybe I
opened the
door no I didn't who knows all right so
let's go to the vagina cuz I mean why
not all
right whoa what the [__] back off bad
back off it oh who whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa chill
out bed just chill out I will no scope
you if I had ammo but instead I will
have to
batong go back and be a normal bad boy
Whoa that oh all right let's go here
Let's ignore the bed cuz I don't have
ammo
okay all right this is another creepy oh
save station what a perfect time ooh
flares we don't need let me just try one
for fun
oh back off [__] can we put one down
there oh that's awesome all right I'm
going to end it here Bros like and favor
if you enjoyed subscribe to become a
part of the Bro Army today because why
the [__] not anyway that's
it there we
[Music]
go never
mind someone like this is not the time
for singing potato
you I mean nothing
but all
potatoes don't for potato oh [__] me